hey i'm alex hein if you guys want to
follow along check out what i'm up to
you can check out modern health monk on
youtube
or my book master the day on amazon
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
it's not too often you get to talk to
somebody who's not only made a
difference in your life but literally in
the lives of millions of people
and that's another my guess today alex
hayne who's
joining us all the way from i believe
the the northern part of the country
we'll get into that in a second
but uh alex has uh been a really good
friend
for no other reason that he's that he's
just such a giving
generous individual it's so gracious and
just a pleasure to
to get to know and i've been watching
him on youtube and not knowing that i
was only
one degree of separation removed from
from you alex
and i want to thank you because today's
my birthday and you agreed to come on
the podcast as a special birthday
present to me
which has two different uh benefits one
is that it's going to remind me not to
eat too much cake
because your foot master of the day has
really
uh has really changed my life it's it's
helped me to lose some weight i dropped
five pounds i always say i dropped five
pounds for my double chin
my stomach i dropped it all the way down
to my stomach nice
you know i also i you know now i'm
within you know those last
10 pounds that are so stubborn um as
soon as i get past the first 47 pounds
then i'll be in that 10 pound zone but
when i get there
i'm gonna look to you for advice because
really you've uh
you've written such a wonderful book or
an audio book and i listened to it and
your voice is monitorous and wonderful
thank you for being on the show alex
yeah thanks for having me brian happy
birthday
thank you so much yeah it's really such
a treat to have you as a
as a guest as a birthday present to me
and
it really reminded me as i was thinking
about it preparing and finishing the
book
thinking about hmm you know now that
i've listened to it to your book
can i even have that birthday cake and
and the thing that
that really speaks so loudly to me is is
your book is really
it's not a diet book it's not a book
about diet it's a book about habits
and those are some of the most powerful
things i think that humankind has or
are habits but so few of us can actually
master them
so the first thing i want to do though
before we get into the book
which is such a helpful book it's got
you know literally hundreds of five star
reviews on amazon and elsewhere i urge
everybody to pick up a copy
and um and when you do you'll be you
know transformed for the good
but i want to start off because you do
so many different things first of all
you're a doctor now
your doctor of chinese medicine and we
want to get into that and how that's
influenced your life but you do all
these things now you're practicing
as a health professional you will be
soon except in the state of california
we don't have to get into that
uh someday uh i want to ask you you do
so many things you're a famous podcaster
an
author um now you're a doctor what do
you think about
how do you characterize yourself who are
you what excites you
most yeah good question i think for me
i'm really always have been interested
in kind of human potential
so the people i idolized when i was
young especially my early teens
i had a natural kind of draw to people
that had attained mastery and
a lot of those people were in the
spiritual
domain or in the religious domain like
the archetypal monk or mystic the hermit
living in the woods was something i
really idolized a lot
but as i got older like you know with
all these career incarnations
um they're all so personal incarnations
you know that are changing and iterating
and i think for me it's just at every
phase of life
uh there's something else that's really
drawing me and really speaking to me
heavily
and it's really just trying to see you
know as i shed those layers of what i
think is possible
what would that next thing kind of be so
i think i'm just here
trying to figure out you know if my life
is a story and everyone's life is a
story what does that really look like
what is the
what is the through line of that and i
think it's
just progression so it's the non-stop
kind of
not not necessarily that every single
day has to be a goal in fact you talk
about the
the problem with goals in the book maybe
we'll get in there what's the problem
with having goals you know i gotta lose
20 pounds because
alex is coming on my podcast i don't
want to look like a fat schlub
uh it motivated me uh what's wrong with
that
well i think you know i talked about
this idea called wedding day syndrome
which is that everybody spends their
whole life planning for the wedding day
you know that's where all the
photography and all the money is and all
of the
the energy is but then no one really
plans for the wedding which is maybe
less flashy and maybe what you should
have done is read 50 relationship books
and
try to know myself and try to know the
character of the person you're dating
so goals are in the same vein it's we
try to
reach this end point and what most often
happens is we end up hating every day
hoping to feel well one day and that one
day is not even guaranteed right it's
not guaranteed a person will lose 20
pounds it's not guaranteed you'll ever
be
the youtuber you want it's not
guaranteed you'll ever get your phd none
of that's guaranteed
and so you're really it's a bet you know
can i put off
liking my life to hopefully one day get
what i want
and you only hear about the success
stories there's that what is it the
survivor or survivorship bias i'm not
sure the term
but in entrepreneurship it's one of the
worst right look i did it you can too
well maybe not so that's that's the big
thing is how can you enjoy your daily
life
but also reach the end point you want
yeah i look at you as not only a
strategist and the strategist focused on
that long-term goal
even though it's not it shouldn't be the
only goal as you're pointing out yeah
the wedding
you know i've been blissfully married
although my wife might disagree but you
know 12 years now we've got a bunch of
kids
um but yeah you're absolutely right
you're going to be in that destination
you know maybe for one day in some cases
but then the
the long time journey which should be a
pleasant one
whether that's with your kids whether
that's with your coworkers
that's the daily work that you're
putting in so i agree with you the goal
orientation but yet
you're unique because you have this
ability this diversive ability
to be both a strategist on the long-term
goal
but a tactician on the short-term goals
and can you lay out
this this sort of structure that you use
in the book you don't it's not a diet
book you have one or two pages or one or
two you know minutes about
you know specific diet suggestions but
that's not the core essence of the book
the core essence of the book is i see it
correct me if i'm wrong is these daily
tactics
and can you say something about how do
you balance the long-term strategic goal
with the short-term daily habits balance
how do you strike such a such a
remarkable balance
i think everything is kind of you know
like in the book i talk about half of it
is the inner narrative the story
and i think of that as like the religion
that's the 10 000 foot view
that's the overall direction that guides
your life the overall principle
and then specifically speaking that
clouds or religion
has to be something about it has to
influence how we change our daily
actions so something about the daily
action has to change
and for me any goal i go after i try to
always
whether it's on a piece of paper or in a
notebook i try to always remind myself
of both
regularly so every day i'm like this is
what i want
or why i want it and then tactically
what is
one thing i can change about every day
to make sure
that you know i'm in the dirt like
garyvee calls it i think he calls it
clouds and dirt
which that is a pretty uh useful
metaphor which is you need to have the
philosophy or the direction
and then also what has to change every
single day so for me that's the way i
balance two things because like i could
say
i want to be a successful entrepreneur
like cool who doesn't
but what's the religion or the emotion
or the story that's going to drive that
to make that happen and then what does
that specifically look like
i try to always do both of those yeah
and it's that's unique and remarkable in
the book you give
you know strategic uh tools to you know
to come up with the ultimate goal but
you say it could be a long game and
we'll get into that one percent
philosophy
which is so interesting unique and
provocative
but also the daily things reminders
post-it notes you know something as
simple as a
you know 10 10 or you know one cent
piece of paper
can make the difference over the course
of a year
uh of you know 10 pounds 20 pounds it
can really affect you in a positive way
and on your youtube channel you have um
you have this striking ability
to create these actionable tactics as i
call but they're not hacks i really
don't think you can consider it a hack i
think of
you know garyvee and maybe i'll just get
into it because i look at people like
garyvee and and other people
i had you know the the musician rapper
zooby on my uh podcast not too long ago
um and and and i've had other people dr
judd brewer who's an addiction
psychiatrist at brown university
and we will put links to all those in
the show but you know a lot of it is
kind of predicated
i feel like weight watchers would go out
of business if everybody actually
followed the advice the first time it's
like okay we did the you know we lost
okay but it's like these things but they
stay in business and they're quite
profitable because of uh
for lack of a better word recidivism so
you know what is the
what is the difference between kind of
these you know many many people who will
get to get rich quick or
get get fit slow you know quick uh roles
and what
you are preventing with with your with
your book and with your podcast
i think the big thing is what we're
really talking about is psychology
so understanding deep psychology about
why people behave they
the way they behave is really the most
important because
just the very fundamental premise
everyone's experienced
someone doing something different than
what they say
right if you've ever dated somebody you
also know that sometimes like you know
maybe a person on the nicer side of the
spectrum may say yes but they mean no
and that's very confusing if you just
take it at face value so
obviously understanding what people do
influences or is a reflection of
psychology
for me i try my best to understand why
psychologically
why am i really doing the things that i
do or why is a person
really doing the things that they do and
when you ask people the right kind of
questions
like what you kind of peel back is that
a lot of it is just um
self-soothing so there's a rough day a
stressful day the person comes home
do they really want to exercise maybe
intellectually but what they're actually
trying to do is they want to feel better
right now
and so i think the big difference is
trying to find the short term
uh whatever makes you feel better in the
short term but also understanding your
own
psychology which is usually through your
actions and i come across
from reading the book and from watching
um from watching your
your wonderful youtube channel which is
called modern health monk we'll put a
link to that
not that you need you know my dozens of
subscribers no hopefully my
my subscribers are rabid they're
brilliant that's what's most important
definitely they're handsome and fit
so yeah beautiful exactly
uh so you have these actionable things
so there are actually takeaways and it
seems to me
i just did you know kind of a google
trend search on your own
website on your on your channel and it's
the most common things that come up sort
of in the world
word cloud are things like uh journaling
meditation um you know if you only had
one
uh a tool in your tool bag which would
it be of all the ones that you purvey
for what outcome for having you know
just
optimizing happiness i think that's
that's the key that i take away
from your videos
i would say it probably would be
journaling but not in a traditional
sense of just journaling about feelings
but a reflect self-reflective
uh self-knowledge type of journaling
because i find that the
deeper and the more complex a thing the
more essential it is to be written down
because it's easier to just turn it into
a mind game
and are those things that can help also
with other types of of issues that
aren't as tangible
you know for example losing weight
there's a there's a tangible outcome
there's a metric that you can
i find sometimes the hardest things to
deal with are things that don't have
metrics like fear
anxiety do you think journaling also is
applicable in that
to those particular types of
proclivities i think especially
that it's especially useful because like
you take fear for example you know i've
coached hundreds of people one-on-one
and the main thing i see
that the reason they don't go after from
weight loss to business to writing a
book they've always wanted to write
is some kind of fear but they may not
have articulated that it's actually fear
but when they speak there's what they're
saying is i'm afraid of
and i found that if you take that person
you just have them write down
what exactly it is they're thinking then
they can actually realize
psychologically
it's actually that i'm afraid and it's
actually that i'm i'm worried about what
my friends will think
if i write this book and then they're
judging me for you know who are you like
to be writing a book
but i think also if it is something even
more intangible
like finding your life purpose for a
long time i coached 20 somethings
and they would always say the exact same
thing which was you know
i have all these ideas and then in a
coaching session i would say okay write
down
every single idea that you have i want
you to write down every idea
and they'd say i want to be an au pair
and go to spain i want to go backpack
around the world
i want to try being a blogger i'm going
to try going
to get my phd in physics i want to try
medical school
and when we wrote down all their ideas
it turned out to be less than 10
almost always and by having that
abstract like
i have all these ideas but making it
concrete it was less than they thought
so i think it's there's a real
psychological advantage to writing
things down
yeah there's a famous scene from the
movie wall street the original one with
charlie sheen
and michael douglas back in the 80s
greed is good gordon gekko
and at one point i think i think charlie
sheen saying to his girlfriend you know
my dream my life dream is to get in a
motorcycle
and ride across china and i'm just
trying to make enough money to do that
now you actually did that in thailand or
somewhere right you actually
and how much did that cost you was that
like 20 million dollars you got to say
it's like 500 bucks right yeah exactly
exactly
so i think most people have this barrier
that they impose it's limiting beliefs
is one other language for it you know
i can't do it it's too expensive it's
too hard i'm not the type of person that
loses weight
uh lose weight but you know you point
out and remind me of another quote by uh
derek sivers who's another kind of um
inspirational figure to me and that is
um you know if
in for lack of information were the
reason we'd all be you know if
information was the key to success we'd
all be billionaires with six-pack abs
and what i love about your book and your
philosophy in general
is um you have a sort of serenity that's
not just like you know gary b's
gary v's a little hyper and a little bit
you know kind of just too
uh too catchphrase-ish and kind of like
hustle hustle
i feel that's like kind of like hustle
porn and or even like failure porn and
you're very candid with your
with your uh audience i mean i subscribe
to your newsletter we'll put links to
that
and you talk about you know why you got
into this why you changed you were an
introvert
maybe you're still a little bit of an
introvert but you're using the tools as
a superpower
to to overcome some of the limiting
beliefs that you might have had before
whether it's relationships whether it's
if you could complete your doctorate
whether it's
you could um you know achieve the the
many goals that you've already achieved
at such a young age it's incredibly
impressive
but i think yeah this kind of um i think
there is an obsession with like oh get
all the information and then i'll apply
the information it's not like getting
your phd right
even your phd or even your doctor it's
not about information is it
right so um what i want to turn to next
is
uh kind of this fascinating um aspect
that i have
you know taken from you is that this one
percent difference
and that a one percent you know people
think if you ask the average person out
there
if you change improve one dimension one
axis of your life
by one percent each day how much would
you have improved by the end of the year
and everyone will say 365 percent but of
course
it's it's closer to about 3 200 percent
because of the magic of compounding
and i want to talk about this concept
that you call habit interest
can you explain that for the audience
yeah so again coming back to what you
were saying
most people fall into this perfectionism
category which is that
this is going to be a great day to write
my book that i've always wanted to write
right it's going to be a great day to
start building my business but when you
look at how they're really built
you know it's really unsexy and people
don't like it because it means that you
could
you could have started any time you
could have started 10 years ago but
all of the books that i'd written i just
allocated the first hour of my day
seven days a week and i had multiple
books out self-published before i was
30.
my own business is another good example
i've never worked 40 hours a week in my
business
i've never even i don't think i've ever
even worked 30 hours a week it's been
an average of three hours you're a
professor also because you know
yeah we work three hours a week on
average just kidding just kidding gavin
knew somebody
i'm just kidding is that with or without
tenure and that's how i win
oh you better believe it's with oh man
but you know even like with my business
a good example
so many people would love to be an
entrepreneur i never in a million years
thought i would be
i've never even worked 30 hours a week
in my business and yet when i entered
school
i just promised i would dedicate three
hours per day and then if i
was too much i would dedicate less i
entered school
this four-year doctoral program with 15
000 youtube subscribers
and a business that was making me like
two thousand dollars per month
four years later i graduated with 315
000 youtube subscribers and a six-figure
business
and that i was if i could have done that
faster i would have
but the point was that i just chose what
was
that kind of lead measure the lead
metric that i have to do
every week or every day and for me it
was published
two videos per week that was it and try
to learn each week and try to improve or
do
something different and it wouldn't seem
like that would lead to the results i
got
and i would not have been able to
predict that because for years i
i wanted that those goals but it was the
very decision to
choose the little thing that you can do
the most often without failing
and then you'll look back whether it is
three months six months or four years
and the growth is tremendous
[Applause]
and it's surprising the growth is
stealthy because
on anything that's an exponential curve
so i'll put a figure of this
in the in the animations in the
background for those of you watching
on youtube uh when you have compounded
interest
for a long time as alex works out in the
book
let's say you want to lose 10 pounds in
in a year
that's stubborn last 10 pounds that i'm
gonna get to after i get to the first
47 pounds when you get to to do that for
you go through this wonderful exercise
like the first 30 days
you lose 0.6 of a pound and that's you
know barely noticeable i mean you can go
and have
literally uh you know a can of beer or
even a can of water and that will
completely obliterate the exact amount
that you lost and even more
and then two or three months three
months later a quarter of a year you
might have lost a pound again that's
something you could
easily overlook then 180 days six months
roughly throughout through the year
you've only lost two or three pounds
uh but then it's that last exponential
half of the year you lose the remaining
you know seven pounds and then you're
there but if you had given up at any
point before then then you reset the
the uh the exponential growth curve
because that compound interest as alex
is promoting which is absolutely correct
it's what einstein called the greatest
invention of the human mind
uh which which actually surprised jim
simons the world's smartest billionaire
he didn't know when i interviewed him
that particular quote so i'll have a
link to that where he was kind of
taken aback by it but he actually agreed
with it and it's really this miracle
that
compounding anything good conversely
anything bad can have so i wanted to
just you know congratulate you for
pointing that
that explanation out and really just
think about it i wanted to give you an
uh you know one other way to visualize
it so similarly if you take a chess
board
and you put one little drop of water in
the first square
and then two drops of water in the
second square three drops of water in
the third square
how many how many squares do you have to
get to before
you flood out an entire football stadium
it turns out you don't even get to the
end of the chess board if you keep
doubling every square
because something like 2 to the 48th
power is this enormous you know
compounded interest
whereas you started in the very
beginning just with a single drop this
is never going to fill up the room even
let alone a football stadium
but that is really the magic of it and
why do you think so many people
give up when they're on that slow part
of the growth curve is it just
natural human frustration or we want
results quickly
i think it's both that but also we're
indoctrinated into doing things we don't
like
i think that's really it like if if i
was like i'm gonna pay you a million
dollars
if for one year you find the most
enjoyable form of exercise
you do it 20 minutes a day people could
probably do that for a million dollars
like they quit their jobs just to get
make sure they get those 20 minutes
so i think a lot of it is we've been
trained to believe there's only one way
to reach the end point and there's not
there's a lot of ways
and the more enjoyable the way should be
the choice um so i think it's there is
that
short term you know the beach seasons in
four months got to get fit
but i think there's also just everyone
does the same thing like they try to do
the hardest most difficult
over-the-top thing rather than figuring
out what's the more enjoyable way to do
it
and as you also point out in a recent
email
you point out that habits are even
better than compound interest you know
compound interest gives you more money
which is great no one's going to turn
down that
but with habits once you accomplish a
habit
then you become the type of person who
has good habits
and habit stacking can then take place
where you can then apply it to writing
your book or writing you know you lost
weight i didn't think i could lose
weight i didn't think i was the type of
person
that could lose weight i didn't think i
was the type of person that could write
a book and then these things become
compound compounding
and i think that's really uh quite a
quite amazing thing to point out
and inspirational to people so i want to
ask you when you accomplish a goal
you've accomplished so much you wrote
many books before you turned 30.
this book is a runaway bestseller and
it's been
influential hundreds of reviews which is
almost about them talking about master
of the day
um you have other books where do you go
from here
you've really done so much at such a
young age now i know you're just
starting off in your
in your chinese medicine career uh talk
well first of all
alex can we talk about that what drew
you to you know to that versus
conventional western medicine
yeah well when i was 22 i bought a
one-way ticket to china thinking i'd
become a monk and kung fu master and i'd
come back with a
a a sagely orientalist who fung chu
trying to be an asian you know this
little white boy watched way too many
kung fu movies
i stay for a year i do learn to read
write and speak chinese
i study kung fu with a guy who is a he's
actually a tai chi
practitioner who was a bodyguard for the
communist party
and i ended up coming back because it
was a good year and i ran out of cash
and i was like well what do i really
like
and i came back and as i was figuring
out my 20s i started building a business
and i had always had lifelong gi
problems even though i was raised in a
healthy family
and as soon as i went to college i
cooked every single day
but i always had digestive problems and
i was always super underweight
and i went through the conventional
medical system i went through a general
practitioner
a dietitian a gi specialist um
and i didn't get any results and i was
surprised by how aggressive
some of the interventions were you know
i was 22 or three
and the gi doctor talked to me for less
than five minutes and said
let's get you a colonoscopy so he was he
didn't
really even know much about me was ready
to put a robot up my butt essentially
and i was like if i was like this is and
we date first i mean
yeah exactly you might be at dinner man
like come on
he's telling me like about his vacation
to aruba in the most saccharine way and
i was like dude your rapport building
skills are so bad but really it wasn't
his fault because it was a system he'd
been trained in
right and so i'm a very systematic
thinker so i just saw him as a highly
trained cog in the system and that
wasn't working very well for most
chronic illnesses
so it was actually a chinese herbalist
that ended up getting me the best
results i ever had in
29 years and that led me to
begin studying this a little bit more
and realize that
since i was a kid this is a lot like
what i'd always been reading about these
kind of
mystic physicians living in the woods
that were hermits and
you know the hero of the saga falls off
the cliff and is revived like
i realized that i always wanted to study
with that kind of person
and it was more of these people in the
chinese medicine field
and so from there it was a series of
years of seeing these
renowned chinese medicine doctors that
ended up resolving my gi problems
so for me the big thing though was i was
looking for really that unified field
theory of medicine
and i did not see that in conventional
medicine and that's why it seemed kind
of so pedantic where it was always
changing
based on research because it seemed like
the core threads
were not that strong but i saw that in
chinese medicine and so that was like
it was like love at first sight that was
really like this is my my purpose my
dharma
so that really resonated with you almost
uh at the
end it certainly resonates with me to
find this universal theory of everything
kind of unification of these ideas
because there are so many different
ideas and so much conflicting
information
it's one thing if you have information
but you have also a decision fatigue
you know how do i decide if i should go
with alex or zubi or you know whatever
and i think uh you know some of the some
of the things that are out there i
wonder from your perspective if um
you know if there is an analog no pun
intended
with all the digital apps that are
useful
in uh for example i use this meditation
app which comes with a band called the
muse band
uh messes up my hair as you can tell but
also
um but also i use you know ten percent
happier
and i use uh this new one by my friend
um rockwell shaw
called mesmerize which is like a visual
meditation app
uh that's quite phenomenal what would
the chinese kind of tradition the
oriental medicine tradition what does it
have to say if anything
about these or is it just like we've
been here for five thousand years
uh talk to us when you're a thousand
years old do you mean in terms of like
specifically the psycho-emotional
stuff going on or just like the use of
technology in
in the eastern practices is it is it
frowned upon is it seen as like just
whatever western our kind of
um liability or how what is the
perspective
from eastern philosophy in terms of
using these apps and technology
to gain mindfulness or develop habits
well i think in general like you have
chinese medicine which is its own
medical philosophy
and you can you could use an app to do
some of the diagnostic stuff i mean
like even with acupuncture they use a
lot of electro acupuncture so a low
frequency
that's just you know kind of mimic
stimulation
but i think in general it would be
interesting to see where
chinese medicine meets technology one of
my mentors is a cancer specialist
in portland and a
i think is a chinese pharmaceutical
company gifted him a thermography
machine
and what's really fascinating is when
you look at
cancer and when you've got a lot of
illnesses in chinese medicine a lot is
due to circulation i mean our top two
killers
uh heart disease obviously
cardiovascular related cancer has a
large cardiovascular component
and what's interesting is that a lot of
the formulas we use are trying to
reintroduce circulation to these areas
that have been impaired for a while
so these byproducts get accumulated and
he showed us some
thermography scans of cancer patients
and you could see
just the areas of heat versus cold like
in breast cancer
you could see just the dark blue areas
in areas around the nipple or on the
breast
and in prostate cancer colon cancer
really really interesting to see what's
what part of the body's really hot
and what part of the body is really cold
so maybe something like that in the
future
um but on the consumer end i don't know
too much yet i know there are definitely
like
uh wristbands for nausea like pregnant
women that are stimulating
acupuncture points the median nerve um
but it's a it's an open field for that
yeah sure you might be the ideal person
with your
you know kind of tech savviness and your
you know
unrivaled familiarity going into this uh
the study in practice
i wanna um uh sort of come come to a
close by asking some
some questions that i ask a lot of
people but um
but i guess i guess before we even do
that um you know the last the last thing
i want to ask
about is is you know pertinent to things
that you can
have direct control over like sitting
down and writing you can actually write
one percent more than you did yesterday
or
or you know i have an apple watch or a
fitbit and i can say well yesterday i
burned 700 calories you know tomorrow i
want to burn 707.
yeah so that literally you can
quantitatively do that what about with
things like
um you know after the book is out or
your youtube channel as you said i mean
you've grown it you know 60x
or you know or something like that in
just a few years that's not something
directly under your control
you said you made two videos a week but
you know were they all the same quality
were you also improving them one percent
per week
uh you know how do you look at it in
terms of things that you don't have
control over such as you know
subscribers and
and critic and commercial success yeah
there's a really good book i think it's
called the
four disciplines of execution okay and
what it really talks about is how
we don't really have a huge amount of
control over many different outcomes
so what we have to do for something like
let's say it is audience growth or it is
something like uh how about finding a
partner that someone wants to date
how do you really control that what are
the metrics that lead to
an increased percentage of that and uh
it's really about
finding what is the closest thing to
something that guaranteed
will affect the outcome so for example
you know like if you're a farmer you
can't control the weather
but what you can control is the kind of
crops you plant and maybe the fertilizer
and the soil you planted in so you
you optimize for what you can control
creating content
i can control the frequency and the
quality
that's a very kind of amorphous
non-tangible thing
but i know if i just control the
frequency that's one metric that will
guarantee affects something
and i can figure out what my system is
for
quality and then try to improve that so
for me it's
what it's trying to find whatever metric
you think is the most related to the
outcome and that's not always easy to
find
yeah so oh that's great
um yeah so i'll put a link to that book
yeah the four disciplines of execution
uh i'll put a link to that in amazon so
people can find that
um great so what i want to do now is
kind of take you on a journey that i ask
my guest that i'm blessed to have on my
on my show
and that really involves kind of looking
back looking forward
in time and connect in some way or
another either to
uh religious or science fiction
traditions as you know our podcast is
called
uh is called into the impossible and
that's named after
sir arthur c clarke's famous three laws
one of which is the only way that's uh
possible to discover what
the uh sorry i always mess up these
three different the only way of
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible
and so i kind of want to ask uh a first
question you know going backwards in
time
what sorts of things did you think were
impossible as a 20 year old you know
usually i ask or
it's 20 something or 30 something but
you're you're 30 something now so it's
not like you're a 70 year old like i've
asked you know
much older people than you uh so what
would you give your advice to your
former self
that um to overcome maybe anxiety about
what was to become your future
so something that perplexed me that
makes perfect sense today
yeah let me give you a cheeky answer all
right
women i spent so much time
being this nerdy dude just trying to
find a girlfriend
and i'll give you an example of how i
changed my philosophy i was trying to
figure out what do women like
right that's the that's the religion up
here yeah what are they like
but i realized i was asking the wrong
question
because the real question was did i
respect and admire myself
right what kind of person did i have to
become to kind of attract
attract the kind of women and really the
life that i wanted
and so honestly that was one of those
things that was
stupefying to me but in retrospect it's
about you know
the more you you invest into your own
self-improvement the more you focus on
living a full life
the more that will not be a problem well
let me know if you figure out
because you're in for a nobel prize
rain check on that yeah that's right
harder than all of theoretical and
experimental cosmology right
um next thing that's connected to sir
arthur c clarke
takes us perhaps into the future which
is i don't know if you've ever seen the
movie 2001 a space odyssey have you ever
seen that movie
oh maybe a long time ago yeah well there
are these scenes kind of iconic where
these chimpanzees or primates or
whatever
they discover this monolith this black
object like this thing over here
and they chuck it up into the air they
chuck a bone up into the air they don't
really understand what it is
and then later on in the movie there's
also the same exact monolith
this huge black you know structure we
don't really know what it is at first
um and that is uh that's found on the
surface of the moon
and it's obvious that you know whoever
put this there was not intending for
primates to find it they were intending
for
the advanced version of the primates in
the long future to find it
and it's sort of a time capsule that
lasted a billion years
or or so we don't know exactly what but
it was put there for to be discovered at
a certain time
so i'm wondering if you were making a
time capsule
um and it was some material object or
some knowledge not wisdom we'll get to
that in a second
some facts something uh something
meaningful that you've discovered or
that you'd want humanity to discover
what would you put on this you know
billion year long lasting usb drive
so there's a great physician in chinese
medicine called sun tsumiao
and a story about him is that he left
some of these most famous chinese
medical formulas engraved
on i think on his actual tombstones and
the reason was that so that the poor
could have access to those formulas to
heal themselves for the rest of their
life
because those were formerly heavily
guarded and i think for me
you know i've been working on this book
i'll show you here that i highly
pretentiously call the masterwork
and this book music yeah exactly
right if i distill but you know the
single most important things
that have made the difference what would
those be and i think you know
whether i give this to my kids i don't
know or something else but for me these
are all things that fall into that
religion category
what are the fundamental principles that
dictate the direction of life
um and it would probably be something
along the lines of what we talk about
which is that everything is one part
your philosophy and your religion that
dictates how you act
but then also what you do and how you
act
so i don't know maybe i'd leave them
this we'll see
in 50 years yeah exactly well yeah
they'll be able to get one of the great
things about writing a book is that it's
there for all time as carl sagan said
a book is proof that humans can work
magic because
you'll have this book or i have a book
you know that i'm reading now
that was written by galileo in 1632
and i'm reading this you know modern
printing of it but it's
it's just phenomenal to think you know
as carl sagan said you have the voice of
a long dead
you know human being in your ear and and
they're communicating to you across the
millennia
in some cases you know i was thinking
and in that book uh this may or may not
be interesting to folks but
in that book he's really railing against
aristotle and how aristotle thought the
universe was centered on the earth and
not the sun
as we now know it to be or you know
later galileo essentially contributed to
our understanding of that
and the books about it it's called the
dialogue and
i was thinking about it well you know
aristotle lived you know in this
a couple centuries bc and here's galileo
so
literally he must have been reading some
translation of it into italian
or latin from the ancient greek and it
was like 1700 years old or more
maybe something like a 2 000 years old
and then he's criticizing this great you
know mind aristotle
uh and then now i'm reading it
criticizing galileo criticizing
aristotle it's just amazing so
it's a phenomenal accomplishment you
have work magic i changed also my slogan
to a podcast is proof that humans can
work magic
stealing that from carl sagan uh
and i really want to thank you for all
the things that you do we're going to
have links to all your
all your materials and where people can
find you online
but um but i really want to thank you
for the service you've done for me
personally
and for our audience and just being such
a gracious uh
humane sophisticated person that is
obviously a deep thinker and i wish you
so
much uh blessing on your journey i know
you're on a mission to do good
in this universe and i want to thank you
for sharing a little bit of that time
that's so precious
with our audience today alex yeah thanks
brian happy to help in any way
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe
comment share rate and review
for a chance to win a free copy of our
most recent guest's newest book
send a screenshot of your review to info
imagine.ucsd.edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information go to
[Music]
imagination.ucsd.edu
find us on twitter at imagineucsd
watch us on youtube listen on itunes
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination in the division of physical
sciences at the university of california
san diego
eric very director brian keating
co-director
patrick coleman associate director
produced by
stuart valco
[Music]
[Music]
you